caroline to be elle est avec nous fend
bonsoir m merci d'être en direct avec
nous au juste cette question les faits
remontent donc au 21 novembre dans quel
état d'esprit se trouve michel est clair
aujourd'hui
écoutez il ya le contrecoup qui est très
difficile à lui pour lui à vivre et un
préjudice qui comme vous l'avez rappelé
est aujourd'hui fortement élevé parce
que d'abord il a été opéré il a été
opéré par le temps de son biceps gauche
a été sélectionnée qu'il a dû être
refixée avec une broche à broche en
titane qu'il va devoir garder toute sa
vie voilà et le préjudice
à cela s'ajoute un préjudice
psychologique traumatique qui est très
important aussi parce que c'est vrai que
dans cette affaire qui est très
difficile à vivre c'est que finalement
sans cette caméra de surveillance
michel est claire serait aujourd'hui en
détention provisoire pour des faits
qu'il n'a pas commis
il ne serait pas devant la justice comme
victimes comme c'est le cas voilà et ça
c'est très difficile à vivre cauris donc
comme vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui on en
est à 180 jours 10 pt et 180 jours ont
été attestés par des experts par un
expert 6-4 par enfin qui l'a opéré et
voilà c'est un préjudice qu'il n'est pas
consolidée encore mais qui fera l'objet
bien évidemment des expertises pour une
fois que ce sera contre éviter au départ
s'était vu accorder six jours d'itt et
un c'est une c'est une première victoire
selon vous c'est que 180 jours d'itt été
finalement conservé vous avez la
victoire ce sera quand michel d'éclairs
pourra à nouveau normal et on en est
loin et est ce que vous attendez
maintenant une peine plus lourde pour
les policiers inculpés avec son passage
à tabac encore une fois voilà ce qui est
très important pour lui et ce qui est
très difficile à vivre pour lui c'est
que sans cette caméra
cette affaire n'existerait pas et il
serait en prison
au lieu d'être une victime et pour cela
il faut que justice se fasse
c'est très important est-ce que selon
vous justement cette affaire michel est
claire elle a pesé dans la balance pour
qu'aujourd'hui justement l'article 24 1
de cette loi c'est qu'ils ont été global
soit revue en tout cas c'est l'intention
du gouvernement
en tout cas lui voilà il ne veut pas
absolument pas dans ce dossier fin aux
procès des policiers ils n'en veulent
pas la police cette affaire c'est la
sphère de quatre policiers contre
lesquels voient la chaîne d'éclair a
subi des violences illégitimes dans un
lieu qui est privé et ces violences
étaient accompagnés de propos racistes
ça aujourd'hui c'est avéré et pour cela
il faut que justice se fasse
mais cette affaire michel est clair vous
pensez que tel conduit aujourd'hui à
revoir la loi sécurité globale ce que
vous voyez qu'il ya aujourd'hui on a
assisté un quatrième samedi de
mobilisation contre ce texte
je ne sais pas qui c'est la ferme michel
des clercs ou d'autres dossiers qui le
complice n'a en tous cas voilà lui
pour l'instant ce qu'il veut c'est que
la justice se fasse dans son dossier
il est confiant voilà il est confiant il
se faisait clair il est il est confiant
pour que justice se fasse dans son
dossier tout à fait alors puisque vous
êtes son avocate sur le plan juridique
pour revenir à ce projet de loi sécurité
globale dans son ensemble mais
évidemment l'article 24 en quoi
justement ce texte peut poser problème
je veux pas me prononcer sur ce texte là
qui est vrai c'est que en ce qui
concerne la sphère de michel des clercs
et ben si tu est important vous riez
vous qui est cette caméra pour filmer ce
qui s'est passé parce que c'est cette
caméra qui a permis aujourd'hui de
caractériser les faits pour lesquels et
quatre policiers sont mis en examen
voilà pour le reste je vais pas me
présenter
merci beaucoup à vous m caroline
to be avocate de michel est clair merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france